este nuevo gabinete ha sido conformado
para enfrentar los principales desafíos
tras la pandemia del cob y 19 y de hecho
este es el gran cambio desde que ésta
arrancó aquí en el reino unido pero
además el primer ministro boris johnson
quiere acabar con dos polémicas que
persiguen a su gobierno la gestión en
educación nacional y la crisis en
afganistán de hecho el entonces
secretario de relaciones exteriores
dominique rap fue removido de su cargo y
designado como ministro de justicia y
vice primer ministro un cargo sin mayor
poder de hecho se considera aquí a nivel
nacional como una degradación dentro del
gabinete y esquerra ha estado altamente
criticado por su gestión en la crisis de
afganistán de hecho cuando kabul cayó a
manos del talibán él estaba de
vacaciones en la playa en su reemplazo
fue designada listas que es una persona
muy querida dentro de las filas del
partido conservador possis por su
posición progress y además el ministro
de educación gavin williamson fue
removido también de su cargo por su
gestión
ocasión nacional durante la pandemia en
la que millones y millones de niños en
todo el país perdieron clases
presenciales fue nombrado en su
reemplazo nadi zawawi quien es el
ministro de las vacunas encargado de
liderar toda esta campaña muy exitosa
del reino unido en la vacunación contra
el coi 19 se mantienen en los cargos top
del gobierno la ministra del interior
pretty patel y el ministro de finanzas
richie son aquí